[Musique]
aujourd'hui je sautille tabriz que je
tél parce que tu as beaucoup de qualité
tu tu es beau tu es gentil qui est une
gens qui travaillent bien
tu as tout ce qu'il faut
moi je t'aime fabrice parce que tu
courrier parce que tu as de beaux yeux
lorsque tu es aujourd'hui parce que tu
les beaux parce que tu
parce que tu m'as ni un essai
m
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu dis un garçon passeport
valide et que jolène comme ça je lui dis
aujourd'hui je t'aime
monsieur pamoate à la batterie pourquoi
les classes défavorisées mais tout ce
que j'aimerais beaucoup que tu sois dans
ma famille et que tu dors avec moi dans
mon lit et je t'aime un peu mieux que
les autres parce que tu es un peu plus
hardis et tu es un bon copain mais il
faut pas que tu te que tu ais dit
idéalise quelque chose c'est juste que
je t'aime un peu plus que les autres
comment tu fais pour le faire savoir que
tu es amoureux en général on ne fait pas
savoir combien de ça dans son coeur
quant à doigts sur mon visage
comment tu fais pour plaire un gars sans
doute que tu as beaucoup je me fais
d'âge mais de vérone du parfum je
m'entends colliers des bracelets
un jour j'avais mais déjà une robe qui
tournait bien mais les vrais amis est-ce
qu'on le regarde avec les poumons d'un
groupe et tous pour notre environnement
est ce que tu as envie de roi c'est
mathieu n'a pas vraiment sa dette
c'est c'est déjà plus que de lui donner
la main ma moi aussi je trouve que c'est
très dur de le faire parce que à la
minute où pour la serrer dans ses bras
mais il lui faire un bisou ce n'est
qu'hier que 20 mois et là mes pieds des
copains merrett
je serais vraiment qu'on est amoureux et
puis quelques fois dans lequel tâche et
c'est très dur mais toi qu'est ce que tu
aimerais faire avec la fille que tu es
en bas on dormira avec elle
ouais on brasse tes mains comme tout le
monde fait ouais bon pour
je sais un signe d'amour pour l'autre
poursuivi condamne pour celle qu'on aime
disons lui a casqué le plus dur quand on
aime ben c'est de garder la fille qu'on
aime moi je dis moi c'est ce que je
trouve le plus dur quand on aime
quelqu'un
qu'est ce qui te plaît beaucoup à elle
en elle ça dépend ce soit parce que les
rigolote soit parce que le sens de
l'humour soit parce qu'elles mêmes
[Musique]
beaucoup de trous très dangereux parce
que le kung fu on dit c est très joli et
puis c'est une chose comme ça et là mais
c'est un attrape nigaud parce que
ensuite où c'est pas son caractère ne
sais pas comment elle réagit pas tu le
lis déjà le tout dans une froide mais
qu'est-ce que ça tu avais fait dans ton
que bah je suis rentré n'a classe et
puis j'ai fait que c'est quelqu'un je
pouvais pas détacher de cette personne
et puis la mettre à celle non pas l'une
s'était pas du tout sur terre qu'est ce
que tu ressens quand tu es très
amoureuse c'est mon coeur qui bat vite
et puis mentalement comme halle aux
grains
c'est agréable c'est désagréable c'est
clair a été souvent amoureuse oui
combien de fois tu sais ton main quand
on est amoureux est ce qu'on a besoin
d'un intermédiaire d'un messager pour
faire savoir
oui pourra vous le dira qu'à son éternel
dit un message et on peut envoyer une
lettre d'amour il dit voilà j'aime telle
personne
tu peux aller lui dire bien mais
s'agisse c'est pas très sûr qu'il peut
trahir
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
toi comment tu fais pour plaire parce
que tu es un an
on peut essayer de freiner quelle est la
différence entre l'amour de l'enfant et
celui des adultes
l annonce d un flot sans humour aux
débutants je suis déjà venu comme ça
même enseigne elle moi je trouve que l
amour des enfants
je trouve que c'est un peu plus clair
que l'amour des parents parce que
l'amour de parents saison et c'est pas
histoire le pauvre coût pour les parents
c'est un jeu quoi pour toi c'est un jeu
pour moi non c'est sérieux
ouais j'en dis toujours dans ma tête que
je dois en parler mais je suis toujours
tenté d'en parler à ma manière
si tu y avait tous les droits y avait la
liberté de faire ce que tu veux avec ta
copine tu es du irait plus loin
peut-être oui mais il faut je vois
finalement que gelée la liberté
[Musique]